you've been on the show a few times
we're excited but tonight I think it's
the first time ever you're singing on
the show I think what are you giving us
I'm gonna give you my new song good I
hope you find it
yes is it off your new album closer to
the truth yes now this is like some sort
of questionnaire and it's like I've got
the facts I've got the facts
obviously you don't you're asking me
your pretty lips okay but now I like you
like it's a classic I feel we're getting
classic share tonight what do you mean
classic it's classic Cher
well you're kind of getting tartan and
well there's a bit of a punk there's a
punk edge engage but nice dark hair yeah
that is it a mood thing do you wake up
and decide which share you will be are
you out of your mind tonight
I was like looking at something it is
like an out-of-body experience it's like
a dream I pack or Mew people are on the
couch but how do you decide you know cuz
there's biker share that's blown share
I'm jealous
yeah yeah just me it's just there just
me in different rappers it's only me
always me just play no me and that it's
lovely to have you here it's
particularly love to have you here
because earlier this year I don't know
if you remember this there was a bit of
a scare bit of a rumor went out and that
you weren't here you must have not you
seen this it was where a Twitter hashtag
went out and people haven't said yeah be
nice read it yeah do you remember this
well no someone told me well this was
the hashtag and it was when Margaret
Thatcher died
but in America people just had like now
that share is dead
there are a lot of people tweeting yes I
got there was a big Twitter fast it was
trending she's dead
and this happens a lot with the hashtag
e thing yes so for instance I don't
remember Susan Boyle
she was the lovely singer Susan Boyle
she was launching a new album and she
was going to have a party
and there was much excitement when she
announced her party
for a ticket
but this is my favorite one like they
cut like what were they thinking so
there's a very posh event here called
the Cheltenham literary festival
so the Chaplin literary festival kind of
went yeah we must let's get involved in
this whole Twitter thing let's be all
over it yeah we like writers and books
and things but we really need people so
they came up with a Twitter name for
themselves at the Cheltenham literary
festival here it is
sadly attendance is very low now good
fine
poor name is their their first pet and
their mother's maiden name so my poor
name is Sookie Duminy did you expect it
to look like that no that is a look like
a cucumber martini to me